[موسيقى]
تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام ست سنوات على
الثوره التونسيه هل كانت وبالا على
التونسيين الا يزداد عدد الناقمين على
الثوره الم تضطر عائله محمد البوعزيزي
مفجر الثوره تونسيه ورمز الربيع العربي
للجوء الى كندا خوفا على حياتها في
تونس اليس من المخجل ان يعود ابواق بن علي
كب سيس واشكاله الى الساحه بينما يضطر
رموز الثوره الى الهرب من
البلاد لكن في المقابل اليس الشعب التونسي
سعيدا
بثورته رغم الوضع الاقتصادي المزري الم
تكن الثوره التونسيه انجح الثورات العربيه
الم تصل الى بر الامان باقل التكاليف اليس
اعداء الثوره رغم عودتهم الى الساحه
التونسيه اوهنا من ان يرجعوا بتونس الى
الوراء الا ياخذون معركه خاسره مهما تغول
اسئله نطرحها على السيده روضه السايبي
الناشطه في المجتمع المدني وعلى السيد سيف
الدين مخلوف الناشط الحقوقي نبدا نقاش بعد
الفاصل
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مره اخرى مشاهدينا الكرام نحن
معكم في برنامج الاتجاه وال المعاكس سيده
روضه لو بدات معك لماذا غابت مظاهر
الاحتفالات عن تونس في الذكرى السادسه
للثوره لم نرى اي مظاهر احتفالات حقيقيه
وكان الناس يعني في حاله حداد نلاحظ غياب
البعد الاحتفالي بعد ست سنوات لان اليوم
التونسي وع وانه وجد نفسه امام وهم من هو
الذي وجد نفسه التونسي الشارع التونسي
المواطن التونسي وجد نفسه امام وهم حتى ان
التونسي نفسه الذي كان يساند ما يسمى
بثوره تراجع عنها واصبح يتحدث عن مغامره
واوقعه به اطراف خارجيه او لست ادري ماذا
حصل بالضبط لكن المشكل اليوم والتساؤل
الصحيح اليوم ما هي نتائج هذا المصار
الثوري الثوره التي سلمت نفسها لفؤاد
المبزع هل تعتبر نفسها
ثوره هل كان قائدا لهذه الثوره ل يتراسها
بعد ذلك اليوم الوضع متازم في تونس الوضع
الاقتصادي اليوم وانا اتحدث معك في هذا
المنبر الشباب في الجنوب والوسط يتظاهرون
وهناك حراك اجتماعي نفس الشعارات التي
رفعت في اواخر 2010 وببدا 2011 اي في الى
حدود 14 جانفي نفس الشعارات وهي هي شعارات
ليست سياسيه شعارات ذات صبغه اجتماعيه
واقتصاديه وهذا دليل على انه ما حدث في 14
جانفي كان حراك اجتماعي وقام بتوجيهه
مجموعه باتصال مع الخارج كيف تفس نفس
الشمره يعني انا لا انا يعني شبه مؤامره
تقريبا يمكن ان تقول مؤامره انا كي غلات
نحكي لك على وضع الذي نعيشه اليوم نفس
الشعارات الان اليوم كنت اتحدث مع عطيه
وهو من احد قاده الثوره في سيدي بوزيد
يتحدث يحدثني عن ماذا يقومون به بال
الاعتصامات امام المعتمديه وامام الولايه
شاب الي
البارحه انتحر حرقا امام معتمديه الكاف
نفس الشعارات التي رفعت ه هل هي تنظر
بثوره اخرى اذا كنا اعتبرنا نفس الشعارات
التي رفعت قبل 14 جفي من ابتداء الاندلاع
من ابتداء حرق البوعزيزي اعتمادا على
الشعارات التي رفعت وقلنا انها ثوره اذا
نحن نته لثوره اخرى
مع مساله رياضيه ماماتي حسابيه حساب يعطيه
ماذا يواجه الاحتفالات متغيبه طبيعي جدا
التونسي الذي وجد نفسه مفكر نحن امام 700
بين 700 الف و800 الف عاطل على العمل نسبه
00 حو حوالي مليون عط على العمل
نسبه فرص الشغل انخفضت بنسبه 25% وهذا ما
صرح به الامين العام للاتحاد العام
التونسي للشغل سيد حسين العباسي 25% را مش
نسبه مهينه 25% تراجع في نسبه فرص في فرص
تشري سنات عليها اذا باختصار شديد لا شيء
يدعو الى الاحتفال يحتفل بخيبته ويحتفل
بفقر ويحتفل بمزي ويحتفل فثم هناك مكاسب
وهناك مكسب مكسب حريه الاعلام و والذي هو
في نفس الوقت مهدد هناك مكسب اننا قمنا
بانتخابات بانتخابات ديمقراطيه اول مره
لكن النتيجه المسار الثوري اين هو من
يحدده
اباطه التهريب
اباطير الارهاب هذا ما حصل جميل جدا كيف
ترد على هذه المقدمه بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم الثوره يعني الثوره كانت وهما
بدليل انه في الذكرى السادسه لهذه الثوره
لا احتفالات لا شيء التونسيون نفس
الشعارات كيف ترد بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
هو طبعا تحليل متوقع جداه تحليل نعتبره
شخصيا تحليل سطحي جدا الاحداث سطحي سطحي
جدا طبعا هو سطحي جدا لماذا
لانه لا نقول لا توجد احتفالات بل نزل
الناس للشارع لكن نزلوا لتذكير الناس
باهداف الثوره نزلوا للاحتجاج على على ما
فعلته الثوره المضاده في تونس وليس كفرا
بالثوره كما تريد ليس كفرا بالثوره طبعا ط
طبعا طبعا ما رفضت الاخت اسم بثوره هو كان
ثوره وما حصل في تونس من
تغيير سياسي هو فعلا لا تصنعه الا ثوره
لما تجد بن علي هارب الى السعوديه وعائلته
بين السجون والمنافي وتجد معارضيه في
الحكم هذا كان لا تفعله الا ثوره يعني
محاوله ان نلعب على
المفاهيم هذا كان اختيار الشعب التونسي ان
لا يصل بالثوره الى اقصاها يعني انا لا
انا انا استغرب انه
والله ل انا استغ يعني انت تعبين على
الشعب التونسي سلميته وانه لم يذهب الثوره
الى الى الاقصى الى الكوارث الى الدم
الشعب التونسي هذا
طبيعته عفوا عفوا عفوا الشعب التونسي
اختار مسارا سلميا ولهذا نجح واختار مرحله
مرحله يبني فيها دوله بناء فعليا يلغي
المنظومه السابقه التي كنت انت جزءا
منها والحمد لله انقذتك الثوره من تلك
الوضعيه اللي كان كان وضعيه مخجله
كثيرا انقذتها طبعا يعني الاخت مع احترامي
لها خياراتها هي كانت مترشح البرلمان بن
علي ومزك بن علي يعني هذا هذا لا يكون الا
في الانظمه الشديده التخلف يعني انا معارض
بس
انتخبوا الحاكم يعني هذا كان من سخريه
الاستبداد ومن سخريه الدكتاتوريه لكن
انقضت الثوره من هذه الوضعيه طبعا كانوا
مستفيدين منها هم يقينا كانوا كان مع لهم
والحصانه ويعني يعتبرون اي تغيير انذاك هو
مؤامره هو خداع هو الى اخره لكن
لكن اقول ان الثوره التونسيه لازالت الى
اليوم رغم كل العقبات تنجز وتحقق اهدافها
اليوم في تونس احنا في مرحله التاسيس لم
نخرج بعد مرحله التاسيس وان طالت قليلا
بجرائم الثوره المضاده لكن الى اليوم
انجزنا الكثير انجزنا دستورا يعني في
العالم قل نظيره انجزنا مؤسسات الدوله
التي لم نكن نحلم بها لنا هيئه مستقله
للانتخابات يعني الانتخابات كانت حكره على
وزاره الداخليه ويحمل صناديقها البوليس
اليوم هناك هيئه منتخبه مستقله اثنين هناك
هيئه لمكافحه الفساد لم نكن نحلم بها لنا
هيئه للحقيقه والكرامه ترينا من في كل
جلساتها يعني حقيقتنا ترينا حقيقه
الاستبداد والظلم وتحذر كل الشهادات من ان
تعود تلك المنظومه لنا هيئه لمكافحه
التعذيب وان تتملص الحكومه وتريد ان تتاخر
في تركيز مؤسساتها لكن تم انتخابها هيئه
المكافحه التعذيب لنا مجلس اعلى القضاء
منتخب وهذا لم نكن نحلم به اليوم القاضي
في تونس لا يتدخل فيه ولا يعينه ولا يعزله
لا وزير العدل ولا رئيس الجمهوريه ولا
زوجه رئيس الجمهوريه ولا بنت خاله رئيس
الجمهوريه القضاء اليوم في اشكال ال اليوم
في اشك وجمعيه القضاه تتهم هذه الل وتطالب
طبعا تم انتخابه المجلس منتخب ويقينا هذا
يقلق الثوره المضاده
ويقلق هناك موقف مضاد لنقابه القضاه يعني
هناك حياه اليوم اليوم في تونس هناك حياه
كنا في مقبره اليوم ثم اختلاف داخل القضاء
ثم اختلاف بين الاحزاب ثم تعدديه حزبيه
حقيقيه ثم
تعديه سيف اليس مخجل بعد ست سنوات وقع
تقييم مرحله بن علي باي ايجابياتها
وسلبياتها وهذا امر حاصل وانت اليوم في ست
سنوات يا اخو ما يهمنيش انا
سرقه ف في بالك انت كنت تتحد انت الان كنت
تتحدث عن هيئه المكافحه الفساد رئيس
مكافحه هيئه مكافحه فساد يقول بعظمه لسانه
في تصريح له ازداد
الفساد في ثلاثه واربعه من ما كان عليه ان
تحكي على الفساد لا انا لا انت
انت كنت الان يا سيف يا سيف كنت الان
تستشهد بمكسب بمكسب هيئه مكافحه الفساد
ورئيس هيئه مكافحه الفساد يتحدث عن الفساد
الذي استفحل وكثر بعد 14 جانفي فرح تحكيلي
على سرقات النظام الصه سرقات اليوم اصبحت
تخالف الراس اطلب اطاحه هي الث الم اذا
كان رئيسها كان رئيسها لا يعكس الواقع
فاطلب بضاعتها في ضم ض ضمن ما تسميه بثوره
وان المشكل ليس مشكل تسميات هذا لا المشكل
المشكل في المضمون المشكل في المضمون ما
هي نتائجه ما هي نتائجه الوضع المزري
الوضع المزري للتونسي التونسي الذي قدرته
الشرائيه اصبحت منخفضه اصبح غير قادر
لتامين سن اطيني ماذا ماذا اسمع
في وتحكيلي على 2011 ماذا فعل ماذا فعلت
النخبه السياسي
لتعترف النخبه السياسيه انها فشلت حقيقه
هناك مكسب تداول سلمي على السلطه لكن
الحكومات التي تداولت على السلطه ماذا
انجزته ماذا قدمته للتونسي ما تحكيش على
هيئه التونسي اليوم يشكي الخصاصه ويشتكي
وضع مزري ويشتكي وضع اقتصادي
ه
يا لم ي يني شي لايني لا هذا
و ما طلبت حت شي انا كنت ع برلمان ما ت
نفس الاشياء ما يقال
وعلني ماعملتش خم ساعات في الطياره مشش
نقيم انت تعمل لانك انت ما تعنيني وما انا
المفروض ماعنيك احنا اليوم نتحاور حول
مشكل في تونس وضع اقتصادي مزري بطاله هذه
جرام الثوره المضاده طبعا
الث تحكي عن النظام السابق النظام السابق
مستشاري الرئيس بما فيهم اخر وزير الماليه
هو مستشار في القصر البرلمان الحالي تحكي
عليه لو ترشحت ل كت في البرلمان الحالي
بما انه العديد من النظام السابق هم
موجودون اليوم في البرلمان في
الهيئات في كل وين تقص تلقى ممثلين الباجي
ق سبسي محمد الناصر رفيق شو اسمه يعني انت
ثوريه اكثر من الشعب الثائر يا ودي الشعب
هو اليوم قال مليت الشعب هو يظاهر في
الشارع الشعب هو في الشارع تحكي تقول
احتفالات احتفالات خرجوا للشارع صحيح وانا
لا اكذبك انت صادق خرجوا للشارع للتنديد
باماره انه في قفصه كان الباجي قا وهناك
عاملين براج كان بعيد عنهم حتى لا يقترب
منه لان الشعب كان ث يرفع شعارات ضد وضد
الحكومه جميل جدا كيف ترد ببساطه احنا في
مرحله تاسيس هي تتحدث نتائج اقتصاديه وهذه
مغالطات الثوره المضاده ان تطلب
الاصايه الصوت الذي نسم الان صوت الثوره
المضاده طبعا تشويه الثوره لا
يكون الشارع يريد نتائج والنتائج لا تكون
الا بعد انتهاء مرحله التاسيس والتي تنتهي
وجوبا بالانتخابات البلديه والجويه لو ما
تصير انتخابات محليه مش راح نشوف تنميه
اطلاقا هذا يقينا ولذلك في الثور مضاده
والمنظومه القديمه تدفع بمزيد تاخير هذه
العمليه او هذا المسار السياسي على امل
يحصل انقلاب يحصل عمل ما يحصل تغيير جغرا
سياسي في المنطقه العفو العفو انا نجاوبك
نقول لك احنا سعيدين بثورتنا وسعيدين
بحريتنا والفساد الذي تحدثت عنه كان يحميه
النظام البنك الدولي كان يقول عفوا
عف هيئه الفساد هو قال مش قال شوق
زمك معقول مع تطرح فكره وتحب تشرح الفكره
فهمها هم رايك وان نعتبر راي غالط ورا
الاستاذ شوقب غالط
الفساد
معع قلق
كلامي الو
لنايل
ي فرق بين فساد تحميه الدوله ويتحدث البنك
الدولي على تقيب ربع الارباح اع القطاع
الخاص كانت تعود لعائله المجرمين فرق بين
انه نتحدث على فساد الرشوه اع 10 دينار و
20 دينار و 50 دينار انا نتحدث على دوله
ينتفي فيها الفساد بعد ان تنتهي مرحله
التاسيس لكن انتم تطلبون نتائج بعد 20 سنه
من مرحله التاسيس اليوم اليوم احتجاجات في
بن قردان من الغباء ان ننتظر وزير التجاره
ووزير التجهيز ووزير الصناعه ان ياتي لحل
مشاكل بن قردان وسيدي الوزير انا اطلب من
الجماهير المحت عفوا اطلب من الجماهير
المحت ان تتوجه بخطاب وترتقي بمطالبها الى
مطلب الانتخابات البلديه الانتخابات
البلديه والتي لا يشارك فيها لا الامنيون
ولا العسكر مش معقول نشهد وهذا التوافق
فين ادى هذا الاسبوع انه تكون انتخابات
بلديه مشاركه العسكر والامني هذ فوق
الصراع لا يعقل ان اخو حم
انتخابيه سيد سيد خليني بس في نقاط خلينا
نجليها طيب انت سيده روضه تقول لك انه لا
شيء يدعو الى
الاحتفال وتونس في حاله ما يشبه حاله
الحداد حاله قلق وحاله قلق والى ما هنالك
من هذا الكلام وانه كل ما حصل وهم طيب انا
بدي اسالك سؤال بسيط كين وضحه للمشاهد
العربي طيب عندما نسمع او نقرا بان عائله
محمد البوعزيزي مفجر الثوره التونسيه ورمز
الربيع العربي قد هربت او لج الى كندا
ماذا يمكن ان نقول عن ذلك ماذا يمكن يعني
لو كانت تونس فعلا لو كان هناك ثوره لو
كان هناك ثوريون يحمون هذه الثوره هل كانت
هذه العائله الكريمه لتهرب الى البعض يقول
لك انه هربت بسبب عدد الناقمين على الثوره
التونسيه الذين تمثلهم او يمثلهم صوت
السيده روضه كيف ترد على هذه النقطه طبعا
دكتور ما تسميه الناقمين هذم صنعهم
الاعلام صنعهم اعلام الثوره المضاده الذي
يشوه ويش اين اعلام والله شوف ل نقر انه
امكانيات الثوره المضاده اقوى بكثير يعني
سلاح الشعب التونسي لم يكن ال لسانه الشعب
التونسي شعب مسالم بينما الثوره المضاده
لها رجال اعمال فاسدون مغيرون في الفساد
وهم بصدد حمايه منظومتهم الفازه لهم اعلام
يملكونه رجال الاعمال هؤلاء لهم نقابات
وساهمت في ضرب المسار الثوري النقابات
وخاصه القيادات النقابيه لاتحاد الشغل
التي فعلت كل شيء وصرحوا انهم كان دورهم
بعد انتخابات 2011 هو عرقله المسار وازاحه
على
السؤال لماذا انتم كثور كن شطاء لماذا لم
تستطيعوا ان تحموا عائله رمز الثوره
التونسيه المبالغ انه هربوا
وانه هم اختاروا هم اختاروا ذلك وهم احرار
وعنا مليون تونسي عننا مليون تونسي يعيش
في الخارج ليسم قياسا لنجاح
الثوره الثورات تبني تماثيل من ذهب لصانعي
طبعا
لنا اخترنا السلميه والثوره المضاده اعاد
تماثيل لمجرم بجيبه الذي قتل من التونسيين
عشرات ومئات انا ما يحصل لو تحاول تقييم
الثوره بالاحداث
المون محمي فق
انا محامي لا
ي
التونسين
صف شهران عيد ميلاد وكل صيف اكثر من 20
سنه من مليارات الشعب التونسي بجيبه لم
ي وبجيبه قاتل وبجيبه مدلس الانتخابات
مثله
مثلو عنده
ب مري فتح المدارس مر هو
م لم تمر عشريه لم يقتل فيها بجيبه
تونسيين ال هذا موضوعنا مش هذا موضوعنا بس
سيده روض سيده روضه سيده روضه طيب هذا بس
دقيقه بس دقيقه لجوء عائله بوعزيزي الى
كندا هذا اللجوء او هذا الفعل يدين
الطرفين يدير الثوره ودينكم انتم
المحسوبين على على الثوره مضاده طيب يعني
كيف تقرين ماذا تقولين عندما تسمعين مثل
هذا الخبر الصاعق هربوا الى كندا لجوا الى
كندا والثورات تحمي على الاقل ابنائها
يعني كان كان المفروض انه الثورات
الثوريين الذين خرجوا للشارع واللي اليوم
هم متواجدين في الشارع كان حملين نفس
الشعارات عليهم ان يحموهم والله لست ادري
لماذا هربوا ولماذا فروا هناك هم عملاله
تذكار نصب اعه في سيدي بوزيد المعقل وين
حرق نفسه كسروها في سيدي بوزيد ال لا مش
صحيح صحيح لا مش
صحيح سيدي بوزيد تعتز بمحمد عزيزي وتعتز
بما فعله وليس لها
مشكل اليوم انا كنت معطيه في التليفون وان
هوني من الواحد يحكيلي يقوللي لن نتوقف عن
الخروج الشاع نفس
الشعار لا حصل لم يحصل اي شي لم يحصل اي
شي نفس
الش الشباب يلقي نفسه للموت هاربا عن اي
ثوره تحدث عن حريه يقوللك اموت جوعا الزم
ب عليه ممكن انت تعتقد كاخ تاخذ في
الملاين وتاخذ الحصانه طبعا تعتقد كنا في
جنه يه الشعب التونسي
يحم الى
جحيم كنت في ملا كنت مع في ملايك مع الملا
عايشين انا
زمن نحكي على الشعب التونسي القلق اللي
عنده هو زيد يتغذى بغياب الرؤيه بغياب
رؤيه واضحه لاداره الدوله وفشل النخبه
السياسيه التي حكمت الدوله بعد 14 جانفي
اليوم هذا سبب القلق الذي يعيش التونسي
زياد على ذلك ماذا الذي اكتسبناه الفقر
التجويع الارهاب ذبح الجنود قتل
الامنين اغتيال
المخب طبعا طبعا طبعا الارهاب عمل
مخابراته
تخب نعطيك معلومه انا نعطيك معلومه شوف
النموذج التونسي هو مثال سيء لكثير من
الانظمه هذا يعلمه القاسي والداني القريبه
والبعيده وعديد الانظمه صرفت مخابراتها
الملايين والملايين من اجل ضرب هذا النموج
وتشويهه تشويه بما
يكون طبعا التشويه بما يكون احنا في تونس
الحمد لله ليس لنا اقليات ولا اقباط ولا
اكراد ولا
غيره الحاله النقيه
لا يعني احنا لعراق سوريا غيره مع معنا 7
مليون ق اثنين ما عندناش عسكر مورض في
السياسه من 50 سنه مثل سوريا او مصر او
غيره فالمخابرات الدوليه لم تجد بابا
للدخول والانقلاب على الثوره وعلى هذا
المسار اع الحريات ومتاع الانتخابات الحره
ومحاسبه القائم الحاكم وحتى جعل منه
اضحوكه هذه ما عندناش في الوطن العربي كله
وفي المنطقه كلها وكانوا كلها ادوات
الاستعمار فاختاروا الحل
الاصعب والدموي بانهم جندوا تنظيمات
ارهابيه لضرب هذا المسار لو الناس في تونس
اذا هذه ليست مشكله الثوره هذه مشكله اد
خارجيه طبعا هم في تونس لصقها في السلفين
انا لما اطلق لحيتي لا يصبح عندي كلاشن
كوف كلاشن كوف لابد من يد خارجيه تضعه في
يدي اليد الخارجيه هي المخابرات بامتياز
وعنا عديد الملفات تنتهي في معسكرات في
دارنا وفي سرته في غيره هذا موثق لكن
هؤلاء لا يعلمون ولا يريدون ان يعلموا
احنا على فكره
الزمن النه زمن كان
[ضحك]
الهب
قتل التونسين
ق وقتل
نفاقه وقتل في اليسار وقتل في الاسلاميين
وقتل
الشعب انتم تبررون القتل انتم تعتبرون
القاتل زعيما انا اعتبره مجرما هذا الشعب
التونسي انت لا تشبهين الشعب التونسي
تشبهين المنظومه الفا
التي
هذا يار وقالك ان اعلام العار هو اللي خي
جماعه البوعزيزي هو يرك الاعلام العار لو
كنت حقا لو كنت حق مؤمنا بالثوره ما كنت
تهر لتحضر
برنام كنت ترفض كنت ترف لديك
الوتب تمر
عب ير
صحيح
[ضحك]
ان
وقول تلفزيون
ت يا
جماعه سجل سجل وقول لقد دعاني من
غربيه
ا خلال سؤال خليني اسال سؤال يا جماعه يا
جماعه يا جماعه اسالك سؤال طيب انت يعني
لم تتركي نقيصه الا ووضعتها الان بمخلفات
الثوره او بنتائج الثوره يا اختي دقيقه
دقيقه السؤال المطروح انا برايي انتم
اعداء الثوره او الثوره المضاده او الثوره
المضاده تدينون انفسكم بانفسكم كيف من
الذي يحكم تونس الان من الذي يفسد تونس
الان اليس ازلام وابواق النظام السابق من
الذي يحكم الان من الذي يحكم هل ابواق
النظام السابق خلعوا القصر ونصبوا انفسهم
مستشارين
هل ابواق النظام السابق ورموز النظام
السابق خلعوا ابواب البرلمان ونصبوا
انفسهم نواب عن الشعب الم يكن الشعب الذي
ينتخبهم وهو كان يتحدث عن هيئه مستقله
الانتخابات كانت تزور سابقا في وزاره
الداخليه في عبدعلي واليوم واليوم الشعب
انتخبهم ها دخلوا هم جو وحدهم خلعوا تبين
نصب الم لهم
انا اجيب عن سؤال الدكتور فيصل قاسم هم لم
ي الشعب الذي انتخبهم بما انكم تؤمنون بان
هناك حاجه ايجابيه وانا اعترف بذلك انه
لاول مره لاول مره بتونس انتخابات حره
ومستقله في حريه اعلام وفي حريه صحافه مع
انها مهدده ونعمه والحمد لله والحمد لله
لكن لكن انك تقوللي رجعوا باماره رجعوا
بما ان كل شي هذا النتاج معنا
حسب فشل مش فشل هذه سلمون مش سلميه الشعب
التونسي هذه اذا كان انت تحكي على
انتخابات شفافه وديمقراطيه وخرجت الناس
عملت حمله انتخابيه متاعهم ودارت في المدن
وفي القرى وعرفت ب انفسها والجميع يعرف من
هم وانتخبه بماذا تفسر جميل جدا بماذا
تفسر
ذلك دقيقه دقيقه خليني اسال خليني اسال
سؤال طيب كيف ترد على الذين يقولون في
واقع الامر انه بمجرد ان عاد او خرج الشعب
التونسي نفس الشعب الذي اسقط بن علي وعاد
وانتخب جماعه بن علي اه وابواق بن علي
وازلام بن علي يعني كل اللي موجودين الان
ازلام بن علي يعني هذا يعني باختصار ان
الشعب التونسي نفسه قد باع الثوره قد ترك
الثوره انت تهلل لثوره وفي واقع الامر نحن
لسنا في ثوره في تونس لسنا في حال ثوري
تونس لم تتغير تونس عادت الى
غير انت اكثر من يعلم ان الراي العام يصنع
وان الاله الاعلاميه التي فعلت فعلها بعد
الثوره واستغلت هامش الحريه طبعا الشعب
التونسي فسح المجال الجميع هي التي اثرت
ونقول احنا في التونسي شلكت الثوره وهمش
الثوره وهمش منجزاتها وجعلت الناس يطلبون
الخلاص الحيني والحلول العاجله يعني في
العامه وسطاء يعتقدون ان الثوره تساوي
الثروه الحينيه لا الاحصائيات ماذا تقول
تقول انه حكومات حكومات ما بعد الثوره هذ
هذ هذه تقريبا خمسه او ست حكومات ست
حكومات بعد الثوره افضل نتائج حققتها
الترويكا بدون منازع حققتها في 2012 2013
وهذا يغيض الثوره المضاده لذلك فعلت كل
شيء واستعملت الاعلام واستعملت النقابات
واستعملت كل الوسائل الاداره العميقه
والامن وغيره واستعملت المال الفاسد في
سبيل انه تضرب طبعا الترويكا وطبعا كان
سلاحها الاول هو الارهاب يعني في فرنسا
وفي المانيا وغيره لما يضرب الارهاب نرى
مشاهد من الوحده الوطنيه مستحيل نلقى حزب
يسب الحزب الثاني ويتهمه بالطوات مع
الارهابيين الا في تونس يعني اللي ترا انه
ثم تواصل وثم ثم
يعني اخذ مع تبادل للمواقع بينهم وبين
المخابرات الاجنبيه انت تضرب وانا ادين
الاخر يعني لما ضرب الارهاب في تونس
مباشره ادان الحز بالحاكم ا ثم الى اليوم
وتاكد انه كانت الضحيه الاولى لهذه
للارهاب والى اليوم لم يعتذروا منه بل
بالعكس يتمادون في ذلك هذه مكناهم
الاعلاميه الموجوده القديمه الث للقضاء
على الثوره لكن الثوره تنتصر وتحقق
الانجازات وتركز هياكلها ولم يتبقى منها
بعد بعد المجلس الاعلى القضاء الا المحكمه
الدستوريه والانتخابات البلديه ثم
ستتشكل جهه وهذا ما طالب به الناس في
الشارع ان ياخذوا سلطتهم بايديهم ان
يفتكوا ويكون مطلب الرئيسي للشعب وللشعوب
الثائره في تونس والجهات الثائره ان يكون
هو افتكاك السلطه والانتخابات البلديه في
اقرب فرصه ممكنه حتى ياخذوا
سلطتهم وثرواتهم وتنميتهم بايديهم وقرارهم
بايديهم بعد الانتخابات البلديه لن يعود
من معنى رخصه من وزير التجهيز او من وزير
النقل او من وزير الفلاحه هناك المجلس
البلدي المنتخب والمجلس ال وال المنتخب
وهذا ولهذا الثوره المضاده بصدد فعل كل ما
بوسعها لتاخير و تجيج الازمه طب يعني
لماذا لماذا تسميه ما تقوله السيده روضه
ثوره مضاده وهي تضع يعني يدها على على على
الجرع على ما على ما يزعج على ما ما ما
يوجع التونسيين الان لماذا نسميها ثوره
مضاده هي هي بصدد وصف الماء بالماء هي فقط
تقوم ببعض التشخيص السطحي للمساله سطحي
جدا طبعا سطحي جدا المسار الثوري المسار
الثوري هو انجازات هو هو تعدديه هي حريه
هي حريه المحاسبه انا نحب نقول اليوم شعب
التونسي شب التونس كل فاسد يصرف عليه يصرف
عليه فيديو على الفيسبوك كل فاسد يصرف
عليه فقط فيديو على الفيسبوك يفضحه قبل
قبل الثوره صفحتي الشخصيه كانت مغلقه لم
يكن لنا من مجال حتى حتى البوك كان مغلق
كنا في مقبره وانتما تحبوا ترجعونا
المقبره بادان للثوره الث
تحات
التحات الاحتفال سيدي بوزيد اطردك
بالحجاره
قيادات من
اهمي ق
شكري شعارات
فيلل شبيب ريبه للسلفيين على بزار
الداخليه وزاره
الداخليه مناد بقتل اليهود هل عمل الثوره
لتقتل يهود تنادي بقتل يهود هذك تو عندي
مسجلين خليني نسال سؤال خليني نسال سؤال
خليني نسال سؤال طيب سؤال بسيط جدا طيب
يعني الا يكفي الا يكفي ان هذه الثوره
العظيمه بعد ست سنوات انجزت الكثير من
اهدافها باقل التكاليف انت تتحدثين الان
عن امور كما قال سطحيه جدا تونس الان تونس
الان لو قارنا الثوره التونسيه ببقيه
الثورات العربيه اولا لديكم مجتمع متماسك
لديكم طبقه سياسيه طبقه سياسيه هناك بعض
الفساد لكن عندما نقارن ذلك بما حصل ببقيه
الدول العربيه في سوريا وفي كذا انتم
انجزت ثوره عظيمه باقل التكاليف فلماذا
هذا البكاء لماذا هذا العويل انت انت
بصراحه يقول لك يعني انتم لا تختلفون عن
المخابرات الخارجيه التي تريد ان تقضي على
الثوره هذه اصواتكم نفس الاصوات المتامر
على تونس وعلى الشعب التونسي الوضع الوضع
الحالي وضع الشعب التونسي اليوم الوضع
الاقتصادي المنهار
وضع القدره المعيشيه للتونسي امن الغذائي
اصبح مهدد امن ابناءه صحتهم هذا ت وضع
اقتصادي هذه مؤامره ممره هذا فشل سياسي
هذا فشل سمي الاشياء باسمعها من فضلك
دكتور هذا فشل سياسي نقبه لم يكن لها اي
برنامج واي رؤيه واضحه تتمسك بالسلطه ولا
تقدم برنامج واض ولا برنامج تنميه ولا شيء
ولا برنامج ولا رؤيه واضحه كلكله كان
معناها اللهفه على امتلاك الكرسي والسلطه
بدون تقديم اي شيء والنتائج
التداين الذي ارتفع مع البنوك الاجنبيه
الدين الدين الذي ارتفع ل كل لدي الدوله
ورت الدوله في ديون لم يستمتع بها ولا طرف
ولا سيدي بوزيد ولا منطقه ولا تنميه ولا
برامج ولا انشاءات الانجاز الوحيد الذي
قمنا به قطعه نقد بز 200 مليم وقطعه تقدي
2 دينار هل تستطيع لك مثال لك مثال دينار
تونسي وضع الدينار التونسي الذي له انعكاس
على على الصناعه وضع دينار تونسي الذي
ينهار يوم بعد يوم هذا نتيجه في يوم ضحى
هل الدينار يسقط بين عشيه وضحاها عن اي
فتره ست سنوات المفروض المفروض ولو نجحت
الترويكا لا يصل وضع الدينار لهذا وصلت
اليه تركتموها تركتموها كبر عل الحكم
الحكم س الحكم س شوف شوف شوف ش
شوور مثل ما انا سالتها بدي اسال طيب انت
جميل تتباهى بحريه الصحافه بحريه التجمهر
بحريه
الاحزاب الانتخابات الحره بالحياه
الثقافيه بالحياه المدنيه بالنشاط المدني
الى ما هنالك من هذا الكلام لكن يا سيدي
وحسبي هذا ط حسبك هذا الناس عاوزه تاكل يا
حبيبي الناس عاوزه تاكل
الناس هذ يشعلون النيران هم يسالون عن
مصدر الدخان يعني كل العراقيل التي حصلت
خاصه بعد سنه 2012 وكم الاف الاضرابات
التي حصلت والاعتصامات وغير هي قالت
يتمسكون بالكرسي ست حكومات يتمسكون
بالكرسي يعني شوف خمسه رؤساء تقريبا سمحني
سمحني لم يتركوا ولو لحكومه منهم الوقت
للعمل فعلوا كل شيء لضرب مكتسب الثوره
الثوره المضاده
طعا طبعا هي الاداره
العميقه انهم اخوياء انهم قادرون على
اقناع الناس انت
تقر اذا كان الشعب اليوم ينفض الحراك
الاجما ضلضل شوف طبعا مش معقول تتكلم
وتفسر نفسك وتاخذ مكاني شوف انا نعرف ان
تفسيري يقلقها
لان لو كنت لو كنت تفهمين ما افهمه كانش
يكون هذا موقفي انا اقول ان بعدض الثوره
للثوره جرحى والجرحى هؤلا كانوا يتمتعون
بالصفقات العموميه كلها كانت لهم اموال
الشعب التونسي وثرواته كلها كانت لهم من
الطبيعي وكان كانوا يستعملوا وسائل
الاعلام لتبييض المجرم بن علي فاليوم من
منذ الثوره استعملوا نفس الوسائل وسائل
علام لتكريه هنا في الثوره وتنديد بالثوره
انا نقول شوف احنا في تونس كنا في مقبره
صرنا في حياه انا صرت انسان صرت نتكلم
بحريه واعبر بحريه وانتخب بحريه واعبر عن
موقفي ولا تتم محاكمتي هذا الحمد لله خرجي
انجاز اخرجني من مرتبه الحيوان لمرتبه
الانسان كان دوري الوحيد اكل واشرب وانتظر
الموت صرت الان انسان هؤلاء لا يريدون ان
نصبح مثل بشر المرحله الثانيه بعد
الانتخابات البلديه سنرى التنميه وسترى
دينار وسترى الانجاز وسرى الابداع اليوم
غير ممكن انك تنتج تنميه من كل الاداره
تنتظر تراخيص من السلطه المركزيه مش معقول
هذا تجاوزه الزمن لما كان ثم مسار بعد
الانتخابات والشعب فرحان بالنتائج وغيره
احنا حتى لو الثوره مضاده ربحه الانتخابات
سنقبل وقبلنا لان ديمقراطيون لان نقبل
نتائج الصندوق انتم لا تقبلون لما طلعت
الترويك في الحكم يعني حروب سنت على
الدكتور موصف المرزوقي وعلى الائتلاف
الحاكم حروب كامله يعني قصف يومي قصف
اعلام يومي انتهى
ب اعتصام اعتصام كان يراد منه انجاز
انقلاب شبيه بانقلاب المجرم السيسي هذا
كان الحمد لله في تونس ليس لنا مقاومات
الانقلاب وليوم ناس داخل قريبه من السلطه
تسعى لانجاز هذا الانقلاب نقول للشعب
التونسي اقوى من الجيش والحمد لله اللي هو
جيشنا الشعبي واقوى من الاجهزه الامنيه
ومن يريد التعويل على هذه الاجهزه لانجاز
انقلاب وقلهم الاجهزه هذه اجهز اجهزه
وطنيه رفض ان تقتل الشعب التونسي رفضت ان
تصطف في في الخندق المقابل للشعب التونسي
هي مع الشعب التونسي ومن يراهنون على
الانقلاب لن يفلحوا لان سنتصدى لهم بكل
دمائنا وبكل اشلائنا انا نقول للثوره
التونسيه ستبقى مثال وهي تتقدم ولو مثال
سي بالنسبه للاخرين ستبقى مثال للشعوب
العربيه و تبقى مثال هو حتى الانظمه اللي
را ف تقتل في شعبها يوميا يعني تغار تغار
من تصرف الجيش التونسي و ال
الا شو من جمله الوسائل تخيل وسائل
استعملوها صنعوا ما يسمى بالنقب الامنيه
لتشويه الناس التقصي يلقش ملف على هذا ملف
على هذا فساد او اخلاقي او غيره ما يلقو
يشوه دقات الامنيه مب مكاسب
الثقات الامنيه
مسجين في
السجون
انا تعرف ماذا صنعوا عننا مثال تعرف تعرف
الامنين الشرفاء قاعدين قاعدين يشوهوا
تعرف عننا امني شريف اهم بانه عامل امن
موازي عبد الكريم العبيدي اللي هو كان عن
رئيس فرقه حمايه الطائرات وزوج به في
السجن 14 شهر ظلما وزورا وبهتانا زج به في
السجن ولم يتكلم احد يريدون ان يصنعوا من
الداخليه من وزاره الداخليه يعني خليه
تخدم الثوره المضاده لم يلقا لا مش صحيح
كله مش صحيح
اصحاب رساله سنم كل وسيله اعلام ام نجد
فيها مكان الحقيقه
للناس
الحقيقه الاتصال الاجماع الي اليوم وسا
الصال اجتماعي
اقو يرفض نرفض الكل اذا كان نحب
ننجح الكل الكل
م هو قال انا انتخب بحريه وانه كان ميت
واصبح انسان ينتخب بحريه والحمد لله وانا
اشهد بذلك انك اصبحت حقا تنتخب بحريه
ولهذا والحمد لله ان الشعب التونسي خرج
وانتخب مجموعه وكم هائل من ممثلي النظام
السابقنا تقبل مانيش نحكيلك على نتيجه
تقبل ما تقبلش مشكلتك يا ولدي مش تحكي على
هذا انت اليوم تحكي على نظام الثوره
المضاده الثوره المضاده خرج لها نفس
التونسي لم نستر تونسي نفس
التونسي يا هذا اقرار بان هؤلاء لم ماه
مقدمين بالصوره تقد فيها ليس بالصوره تقدم
انت والانتخابات هي والصندوق هو
الفيصل جاي صندوق اخر وزال متواجدين
تداول منابر الاعلام التي يديرها كل منبر
اعلامي يمتلكه رجل من رجالات النظام
السابق وانت وغيرك تهير لتقدم مع انه كل
مع انه التكنولوجيا الحديثه وفرت لك وسائل
لايصال صوتك وتخلق شعبيه من خلال تسجيلات
لك خاص
وتبين للناس لكي يحسم انت فاهم يا اخي
غيرك غير
فاهم التونسي لا يفهم كل شي عندما يراك
التلفز في منبر يقول
منت التونسي الذي اختار وانتخب بنزه انتخب
بنزه انت ق تغلط فيه نضرب ضربه نمشي
ابراهيمي نرب ضرب نمشي سمير الوفي كلمه حق
ح عندك و
اتصال متناس مع ن متناس انت مخ في مخك
متنا
لقص كيفاش انا انقد شي واذهب اليه انقد
بيت ان على بيت خور واذهب اليه يق عن نس
يخر غيرصحيح السلميه بعك على
الارهابين على الارهابيين
انت تعيش
بمالم الامنين
مايقولها سيفدين
مخلوف الوح
تفلي يا جماعه خلص الوقت خليني اسال سؤال
بس دقيقه
واحده دقيقه بس باختصار شديد انت تركزين
على الوضع المزري على الجانب الاقتصادي
قالك قريبا جدا ل لا لم اركز قال هو قريبا
جدا ست سنوات وهو مازال رجعين اعطيني
تقييم المرحله هذه تقييم المرحله هذه
مرحله فشل كلي انا قلتلك ثم ثلاثه مكاسب
قلتلك واقرت ان هناك ثلاثه مكاسب تداول
سلمي على السلطه انتخابات ديمقراطيه وح
صحافه حره اع حر مع انه بالرغم انه مهدد
وهذا ما صرح في العديد من الناس مهدد
والله شكون
منكم منكم فهمت عليه انا انا سيدي نستعمل
في الاعلام وهدد به يا اخي اصحاب الثوره
ما يروحش يحسوا يفسروا للناس للشعب انهم
مقاطعين هذا الا مكان
مكان انهم قه
الز دكتور هذ يسبون الجزيره واول من يهون
ال انا لا اقاطع احدا انا لا اقاطع احدا
انا لا اقاطع احدا
انت انت مشيل لهم مامهم ماموش ما تمشيلو
ملا مع
ذاتك
نمي بس خلينا نشمل الموضوع خلينا نشمل
الموضوع نشمل الموضوع انته تقريبا
الوتص اين اين ذهب وثور تونس الاحتجاجات
الجاريه حاليا انا اقراها بشكل جميل انه
ضمير الشعب التونسي حي وسيدافع عن ثورته
وسيندم والناس المحتجين اليوم في سيدي
بوزيد والقصرين وقفص وبردان والمكناسي
والكاف وغيره هم ضميرنا هم ضمير الثوره هم
الذين سيتحرك كلما احسوا بارتداد نحو
الماضي الذي لن يعود وانا ابشر ابشر انه
المنظومه التي جعلت من تونس دوله متخلفه
وجعلت من الامه العربيه امه متخلفه والتي
لم تصنع معلوماتك دكتور فيصل في خلال
تاريخها الا
واحده جائزه نوبل في العلوم واحد فقط
الدكتور سويد في العلوم اقول البقيه دول
اقل منا بكثير نعم صحيح في عشرات الفائزين
هذه المنظومات الفاسده التي لم تكن تعيش
في ظل دوله بكل المقاومات التي نريد هذه
المنظومه لا تنتج الا الجهل والتخلف
والفقر والتبعيه اليوم حصل مؤتمر
الاستثمار في تونس والصين الشعبيه اقترحت
ضخ 11 مليار دولار لكن الحكومه التي الله
غالب تحكم فيها فرنسا الى اليوم فرنسا
اليوم هي المقرر تستعمل كل وسائل
الضغط شقو يعني وين
شغير الشعب التونسي بعد انتهاء مرحله
التاسيس ولذلك انا لا احلم
بالكثير ادع الشعب التونسي الى الارتقاء
بمطالبه الشعبيه الى انجاز الانتخابات
البلديه وانجاز المحكمه الستوريه جميل
بعدها سياخذ قرارهم بانفسهم سيتولون
امورهم بانفسهم هناك تبب التونس لم يعد له
ثقه في النخبه السياسيه فجل كلي لم يعد له
اي ادنى ثقه لو تقوم باي تنجز اي انتخابات
فلن يذهب الى صناديق الاقتراع هناك فجل
الاخر الدبلوماسيه لم تقم باي دور هناك
اليوم دبلوماسيه موازيه خط امريكي خط قطري
خط فرنسي كل يتحرك من جهته باختصار بجمله
واحده بعد ست سنوات ماذا تقولين عن
الثوره ووف وقل ل المواط اشكرك جزيل الشكر
بجمله واحده حاله الثوره كلها خير الثوره
ماشيه للحريه وماشيه للثروه وماشيه
للتنميه الشعب ان يرام اشكرك لم يبقى لنا
الا نشكر ضيفين السيد سيف الدين مخلوف
والسيده روضه
السايبه نلتقي مساء الثلاثاء المقبل فحت
ذك الحين هو فيصل القاسم يحييكم من الدوحه
الى اللقاء يعطيك العافيه
[موسيقى]
ان